most folks really think of Washington as
a general or president not as a
businessman an entrepreneur and when
they come to learn about what he did on
his own property and the fact that right
after the presidency he launched this
huge whiskey business it fascinates him
why should be America's distinctive
spirit and not bourbon um the fact is
when when the tea went overboard in
Boston Harbor that's not the only thing
they threw overboard
most Americans as we grew into a nation
we're used to drinking rum but after the
Revolution you know there's an anti
British taste in our mouth and part of
that's the taste of rum when they quit
using rum that didn't mean they quit
drinking it just meant that they
switched over to indigenous things and
that and the main thing that they
switched over to was rye whiskey because
that's what was prevalent Americans
turned away from those British products
and in this whiskey drain out the hall
became really our drink so the fact that
George Washington decided to get into
the whiskey business was not viewed as
strange or unusual in any way it was
part of the American economy in a very
vibrant part of it
there are different perspectives on why
we do this project here of making
whiskey at Mount Vernon number one for
those of us who make it it's an
incredible opportunity as historians to
be involved in doing this the real way
the old way and we gain a lot from that
and it helps us become better historic
interpreters secondly it brings a lot of
attention to Mount Vernon people are
interested in Washington and the whiskey
story I'm here helping the folks at
Mount Vernon operate George Washington's
distillery in a manner that was
appropriate for the 18th century time
that it actually operated the historical
nature of it is something that that
really strikes a chord with me you know
I I have an incredible sense of history
and and whether I'm making it or just
participating in it is is a fun deal for
me in the late 18th century the
distillation equipment was essentially a
piece of farm equipment and basically
every every farm had had a set the
research we did indicates that there
were 3,500 distilleries in Virginia
alone in the late 1790s early 1800s and
and you know in George Washington's was
no different he had fart five farms I
think it was on the site and one really
nice-size distillery making whiskey at
Mount Vernon it's always a bit of a
challenge because we choose to continue
to use 18th century means and methods
and it's handwork it's lifting carrying
grain stirring with large rakes mostly
it's just back-breaking manual labor
when we start out we have to get about
30 gallons of boiling water into the
mash tub and that's accomplished by it
by a conga line of people that take
turns dipping a wood bucket and the
boiler and carting the water over and
dumping it in a mash tub and stirring
the grains in is an incredibly manual
procedure we have a a long-handled pole
probably six feet long with with some
wood slats at one end help stir and it's
very much like a rolling action if you
could imagine though growing a robe
through oatmeal then we've got again a
bucket brigades to get it out of the
fermenter stand over to the still bucket
brigades to get it out of the still and
send it over to the farm there's just a
lot of cart and stuff around here that's
that's just not done anymore in modern
distilleries because the advent of pipes
and pumps
I think we got a new perspective on the
lives of the people that worked here in
the 1790s you know we run the numbers a
lot and look at what we did and at about
two weeks time and we made about a
hundred and thirty-four gallons of
whiskey in 1799 they made eleven
thousand gallons which means they had to
make about thirty to fifty gallons a day
I used to think that it was gonna be
random there's gonna be hit and miss it
wasn't gonna be particularly good that's
why people started putting whiskey and
charred barrels or running it through
charcoal or making juleps is because
they're trying to knock the rough edge
off of the spirit that needed at the
edge not thought but after the first
round of making George Washington's rye
I came to completely different
conclusion because by golly I'd drink
that stuff right off too still all day
long it's good it's good and then being
on edge though it's a little a little
stronger than we're used to it doesn't
have the flavor of the barrel to it to
be called rye whiskey it has to touch a
brand-new charred barrel even if it's
new make spirit if you want to call it
whiskey it's got to hit that new barrel
certainly we did it as much as we could
to the methods of the 18th century but
you do have to make some adjustments in
order to make everything work too to
comply with the law we buy a brand new
barrel and we dump the alcohol in the
barrel mix it up and dump it right back
out again there was no requirement in
George Washington's time to actually
throw it in a barrel and I would assume
that on a case and they sold it directly
in jugs to people so there's certain
compromises you have to make but all
that being said it's very accurate I
think to what Washington had and I'm
sure that if he walked in here he might
point out a few things that are a little
off but I think probably we got it
pretty close and he would probably be
pleased that it's here along with the
mill that people are learning about his
businesses
you